welcome to my new series on the five
most stunning or slightly different
forks that you will see in a game of
chess remember to subscribe and like
this video that will move straight into
these amazing examples well this first
example has a slightly feel-good feeling
to it we have the current world champion
at the time and totally cop off with the
black pieces and it's only on move 11
and in this position he plays Bishop to
d6 and unbelievably bad move and after
White's next move
Karpov resigns immediately maybe this is
an example of falling into a fork at the
highest ever level Karpov losing this
game in a rather embarrassing fashion
can you find the move that his opponent
Larry Christiansen now played he now
played Queen d1 and this is a classic
fork the Queen is attacking the bishop
and the knight so is creating a fret
against two different pieces
simultaneously and there's nothing that
Karpov can do so he resigns on move 12
oh dear oh dear Karpov time to hit the
bar maybe we've actually using lots of
world champions today in these examples
of forks and Magnus with the black
pieces here is playing against 960 world
champion at Wesley so and he now pulls
off a very nice pretty combination to
gain a major win of material so imagine
you're black here maybe the fork is not
in this original position but we will
lead up to it and it's the fork that
wins the game slightly harder than the
last one Magnus the play and how does he
basically force resignation well he
starts off with Queen takes d1 Czech
giving the Queen up for the rook
Wesley actually resigned in this
position seeing the future I suppose if
you see your imminent death you might as
well just end it now
and the idea of this is after Bishop
takes d1 try to work out the idea if you
can remember that you do have the pause
button available rook to e1 is a forcing
move White's King has to move forwards
and now we come with another check on f1
the King can't go backwards now because
if it does Bishop to h3 is actually
checkmate so the King has to come to f3
and now the killer fork Knight to e5 and
again a move that creates a direct
threat against two different pieces the
two most powerful pieces in this
position crystal crystal clear they're
from Magnus proving he is a brilliant
tactician we now come to a 1966 world
championship match and this was between
petrosyan of the white pieces of very
strong player known for his positional
play more than anything but as we see
here he's pretty good at some tactics
and Spassky Boris Spassky with the black
pieces and this was a really big moment
in the match and in this position as
Petrosyan to play with the white pieces
can you find his move
maybe Spassky was guaranteeing or hoping
should I say that white would take on f7
when he has some survival chances but
there's a much stronger move and this is
a motif well worth remembering I've used
it in some my games before and the whole
thing about these tactics these Forks if
you remember the sequence and you
picture how the piece is moving you
might be able to prove your own game by
putting it into motion there the move is
Queen to h8 check it's like for throwing
a thunderbolt on the board Spassky
must have been really shocked had he not
seen as gumming and the point of this
Queen well I say sacrifice not really a
sacrifice is there after the night after
this mood the night becomes merchants of
havoc and it can jump into f6 creating
this mammoth fork and
next move winning the Queen piece up and
the game is over lovely crisp tactics
from Petrosyan what a fork as I said was
defined really when a piece attacks two
different targets but you can sometimes
self fork and this is a very high level
thing to do if you're trying to attack
and it often comes in this kind of pawn
structure we see in front of us here
this is taken from the match between
Bobby Fischer with the white pieces and
Macau is how to amazingly strong players
and the candidates run up in 1959 and
here Bobby goes Bishop to d5 he's
walking and talking himself pronounce
that very carefully if you try to say it
he could get in trouble
the forking he's doing is the rook and
the knight but he's also going into a
fork his knight and Bishop there's
forking all over the shop here too many
Forks for my brain to calculate and this
is an amazing idea and a beautiful idea
and the point being if tau now takes the
bishop then we have Queen takes that d5
and the threat against the rook and the
knight gives white a winning game and
had after this move black taken the
night we just take the rook in the
corner winning material so tower has to
play rook a7 and after Bishop takes e4
Bobby Fischer gained a nice advantage
even though he went on to lose this
match which is featured in one of my
favorite books of all time Macau tails
life and times well worth buying that
book if you get a chance both brilliant
players from another era but this whole
idea of self walking very interesting
very beautiful and it's something that
we rarely get a chance to play on the
board let's finish off my pick of five
amazing Forks I found a very bizarre
example here
and this one I found while searching the
internet and it's black to play and to
win believe it or not a game taken from
1921 not with any really recognizable
names the player the black pieces is
called a man hi MA and it's really
bizarre but can you see the mood that
forced resignation and this is a very
unique fork here everything of white
seems to be well defended but one move
of blacks a real again bolt from the
blue is a winning idea what is the move
here well the move is the unbelievable
rook to e4 and this is a
discombobulating move discombobulating
white's rooks here which were defending
each other but can no longer muster a
defense for example if Bishop takes rook
black can simply take that bishop with
either pawn and we can see that the
black King has created a fork really
amazing stuff and black goes a piece up
and there's nothing really much that
white can do here if white tries rook
takes then black will again take with
the pawn and there's another fork
because we're attacking two different
pieces this time the bishop and the rook
so that's one of the more bizarre
examples rook to before I can find over
the Internet
well you often find bizarre things when
you search over the Internet that is
true thank you for watching this video
remember to like and subscribe which
helps me helps the chess community and
I'm rhyming badly that was terrible and
some I think stunning examples of forks
there and historically important folks
from chess history which was your
favorites can you think of any that I
may have missed out that you think
deserve to be in my selection goodbye
for now I'll be back again in the near
future